complexity series let's be going to be
given by Nicole who is going to become a
faculty member Michigan so congrats and
without further Ado let's take it away
okay hi everybody uh it's nice to be
here so I'm here as a Simon's fellow for
this semester and then later I'll be at
Michigan before that I was a PhD student
with Virginia who you just heard speak
um okay so Virginia talked in her talk
about kind of an overview of
fine-grained complexity and the
different types of areas and problems
that can be applied to and in this
second talk what I'm going to do is zoom
in on one of the particular areas that
it has been particularly successful in
and that is uh distance problems in
graphs
okay so today we will see some examples
of fine-grained hardness for distance
problems in graphs
and I've heard from the organizers that
these problems can be expressed
naturally as a recursive database
queries so if that's a motivation point
for you then great and if it's not then
that's also fine uh so just as a first
thing like I don't I don't generally
work in databases or logic and so some
of my I want to make sure this talk is
clear to you and so if I have different
terminology than what you're used to
then I hope that you will clarify
okay so what I want to start with first
is like a more broader takeaways from
fine grain complexity since this is like
the boot camp of the
um like introduction to fine-grained
complexity and some of these will appear
later and this is kind of like a preview
of what are some of the what I view as
some of the broader takeaways so the
first one which Virginia mentioned is
like oftentimes we find that like the
textbook algorithm turns out to be the
optimal one
but there are of course cases where the
textbook algorithm is not the optimal
one and fine grain complexity can also
help us figure out when that's the case
so one point here is that like even if
all of these conjectures and stuff turn
out to be false this has still been a
useful tool in terms of finding
algorithms because for example people
have looked at the whole landscape of
all the problems we've been able to
prove hardness for and said wait here's
a problem we can't prove hardness for it
and so maybe we can get a better
algorithm so it helps tell us which
problems that we really need to focus on
working on for algorithms and this has
come into play in some of like the
recent breakthrough Works talk to some
of the authors on like uh Max flosens
okay set second takeaway is that you
know some fine green complexity
reductions have this nice property that
they're actually simple enough to be
taught in courses
uh the one Virginia showed you earlier I
would say is and I'm going to show you
some also that are
um
of course there are some that become
very involved and complicated but like
the fundamentals of this area I would
say are accessible and that's a nice
property that we can actually be
teaching people who have just taken like
one undergrad algorithms course like
some of the fundamentals of this okay
another takeaway I would say is that
there are some like surprising types of
reductions in fine-grained complexity so
one of them is like that you can kind of
make an assumption about an exponential
time problem and then get as a
consequence something about a polynomial
time algorithm and that's what you saw
earlier today with Virginia reducing
from the strong exponential time
hypothesis about KSAT down to the
orthogonal vectors problem which was in
polynomial time so that's kind of maybe
surprising on first glance that you can
do that a second one is that you can go
from large output sizes to small output
sizes so for example
um what you're going to see today that
I'll talk about later is you can go from
all pair shortest paths where the output
size is N squared
and then you can reduce that to a
problem where the output size is just
this one number and maybe that seems
surprising on first glance and I'll show
you an example of that it's the negative
triangle one that Virginia mentioned
earlier and then a third type of maybe
surprise is that you can kind of take
one single assumption that has like
that's just about the exact time
complexity to get an exact answer for a
problem and it turns out that we can
transform this into getting lower bounds
for conditional lower bounds for like
whole like time versus accuracy
approximation trade-offs just by like
making this one exact algorithm
assumption and you'll see also an
example of that later I would argue that
fine grain complexity is an exciting
field with active new developments and
that's an another possible uh takeaway
and then finally
um you know maybe given this
introduction to this field you can find
some of your favorite problems and see
if they're viewable through the lens of
fine grain complexity or not
so with those high level things let me
now get down to some actual definitions
of problems Etc so again we're talking
about distances and graphs
and the first parameter that I want to
Define here is the eccentricity of a
Vertex so we have a graph and then the
eccentricity of a Vertex is just going
to be the farthest vertex from that one
the diameter is going to be the maximum
eccentricity in the entire graph the
radius is the minimum eccentricity in
the whole graph and here's a picture
that might help so the diameter is just
going to be like the single largest
distance in the whole graph
and the radius is the one with the
minimum eccentricity that is to say
there's some vertex called the center
for which it is distance at most radius
from everybody else in the graph
there's also this parameter called
median where it's the minimum overall
vertices and then you take the sum of
the distance to everybody else
and the point here is that actually
something that might seem surprising at
first if someone is not familiar with
these algorithms is that like the best
thing that we know how to do to compute
these things like you just want to find
the diameter you just want to find the
one single biggest distance in the graph
the best thing we know how to do is to
compute all of the distances in the
whole graph
write down all of them in like an N by n
Matrix and then just take the biggest
one and that's the case for all of these
different problems
and so in particular that's going to
take time like n cubed for dense graphs
where you have like N squared vertices
uh and sorry N squared edges and then
for sparse graphs that's going to take
like N squared time
uh to run all pictures fast so these are
like the two running times that we're
working with and that we want to show
hardness to say in dense graphs you
can't do anything better than cubic and
in sparse graphs you can't do anything
better than quadratic
okay so that's the question here
and then there's another question which
is maybe we want to approximate these
things and we can also ask the similar
questions
okay any any questions so far
Yeah question
um so
oh thank you yes so the question was
about
um I've just mentioned Denson sparse
here what about the regime when your
density is in between these things
so at least for the sparse reductions we
don't know how to make them any better
for a denser graph
and similarly for the dense reductions
are there maybe I'll pose if Virginia if
you know anything about things in
between I I don't think I do it's
depending on what assumption you're
making
endpoints it's a good question
okay so the outline of today is that I'm
gonna it's gonna be split into two parts
first we're going to look at sparse
graphs where M here denotes the number
of edges and that's approximately the
number of vertices then we're going to
look at dense graphs and these are
almost going to be like two totally
separate talks even though we're talking
about the same problem somehow the
sparse and dense regimes are quite
different
and you know it's maybe an open problem
to kind of understand maybe more
relationships between them but for now
they're actually you're going to see
quite different two quite different kind
of talks okay so let's start with sparse
graphs
okay so in sparse graphs again the
question is can we solve these problems
that we care about eccentricities
diameter radius median can we solve them
in a sub-quadratic time that is like n
to the 2 minus Epsilon
and the answer turns out to be no under
some hypotheses
after that we can ask the question of
what about approximation what if we only
care about getting a returning a
solution that's within let's say a
factor two of the true diameter
for example and it turns out the answer
is yes you can get some very interesting
approximation algorithms here that are
subquadratic but it only works up to a
point and you can show also lower bounds
conditional lower bounds that say you
know under some hypotheses you can't get
anything better than a particular
um
accuracy of approximation
okay so let's be a bit more specific
here so
these are the best known approximation
factors that we have for sub quadratic
time algorithms for diameter and radius
you can get a three halves approximation
you can do this in N to the three halves
time
for a sparse graph for eccentricities
the the approximation ratio is a bit
different It's Five Thirds for median
you can do one plus Epsilon and M over
polyepsilon time and we're asking the
question of you know
are these things tight and it turns out
yes they are so we can show that these
particular approximation factors are
tight under certain hypotheses
so what do I exactly mean by that is
if I want to get anything better than
like a three-halves approximation for
diameter then suddenly I need I need N
squared time
that's what it means for these factors
to be tight
and the running time too
uh yes you can also show that for these
particular algorithms if you want to get
anything better than this running time
then the approximation factor is going
to go up
okay so this is kind of what the world
looks like in the sparse regime
so earlier today you saw this reduction
from KSAT down to OV that Virginia
showed and then what you can do here is
take OV and reduce it to uh this three
halves minus Epsilon approximate
diameter as well as eccentricities
it turns out that we need a bit of a
different hypothesis to deal with these
other problems radius and median
we call this the hitting set hypothesis
I'm not going to Define it here
but it's similar to OV but it has uh but
it has different quantifiers like
different for all there exist
quantifiers
that kind of match the quantifiers in
the radius problem
and for that you can get you can get a
reduction uh from here to here
okay so what we're going to see today is
I'm just going to focus on bringing OV
reducing OV to diameter
and this is one of those reductions
that's actually simple enough to be
taught in a class and furthermore I I
know that some people teach in classes
like first
going from KSAT to OV that Virginia
showed you and then going from OV to
diameter and I think that's a really
nice like example nugget of fine grade
complexity
okay so let's get into this
so let's first recall what the OV
hypothesis is
so it's the orthogonal vectors problem
and then we're saying given a collection
of capital N binary vectors of length
roughly login is there an orthogonal
pair that is is there dot is there a
pair with DOT product zero the way that
I really want you to think about this
problem is kind of ignoring this
um and just looking at this
so what we can imagine is that each
Vector is like the indicator Vector for
the presence of elements in a set that
is to say we have a universe of size log
n each of these vectors is expressing I
have this element I do not have this
element I have this element and it
represents a set and then all we're
asking here is is there a pair of
disjoint sets so this is like a set
disjointness problem
is that okay
Okay so
the OV hypothesis again is that OV
requires uh
quadratic time where n is n here is the
number of vectors okay
so you already saw also that the strong
exponential time hypothesis implies OV
so any reductions we can get from OV
also follow from the strong exponential
time hypothesis
okay so now I'll show you the reduction
and this is a reduction from OV to
approximate diameter
and our goal is to say the following
we'd like to say that anything better
than a three-halves approximation for
diameter if you can do that in time sub
quadratic then you can get an algorithm
for OV that is also sub quadratic
so that's our goal yeah
sure
oh the tilde is suppressing log factors
you can change one Epsilon to an Epsilon
Prime and remove it until then yeah
okay so here's the construction so we're
given an instance of OV which is a
collection of sets here
reflection of subsets of the universe of
size log n and what we're going to do
we're going to create the following
graph there's a Vertex here for every
element that is to say every index of
the vector so this is like the ground
set that we're picking from ABC and then
there's also a Vertex for every one of
these sex aka the vectors and so these
sets could be for example a b c a b Etc
and we're just going to add edges in the
natural way that is we're just going to
add edges from this set to each of the
elements so from here to a b and c from
here we add an edge to A and B Etc
and that's the entire construction
there's also a clique here so imagine
all of these vertices here are uh in a
clique there's an edge between all of
them
okay so that's the entire Construction
and now we would like to show that if
you can get a better than three halves
approximation for diameter on this
particular graph then we've solved OV
so let's consider the two cases
let's first consider the case where
there is no pair of disjoint sets and my
claim here is that in this case the
diameter is two
so why is this the case this is the case
because we can say okay if we don't have
any pair of disjoint sets then every
single pair of sets here
is some element and therefore both of
them have an edge to the same element
and then the distance between them
becomes two
okay and then you also need to consider
other types of pairs of vertices so for
example pairs of vertices in here those
all have edges between them so those
ones are also of distance at most two
one and then also a one vertex in here
and one vertex in here again they have
distance two because you can take an
edge here and then take one of The
Clique edges
okay so this shows now that if you do
not have a pair of disjoint sets then
the diameter is two
okay now we need to do the other side so
now we're going to say if there does
exist a pair of disjoint sets then the
diameter is at least three that's the
claim
and the reason is okay let's look at
these two sets they are disjoint
now what does that mean that means that
there does not exist any element in here
such that they both have edges to them
so there's no path of length two between
them like this
and therefore their distance is at least
three and so the diameter is at least
three
okay so now to yes
I'm sorry so it should be
yeah you can definitely get from here
considered everything
what did you say it was empty sentence
then he said we'll have an edge to The
Click oh I see
if you remove it then you're fine
okay so now to conclude the proof what
we're saying here is that if you had an
approximation algorithm that was gave
you approx multiplicative approximation
Factor better than three halves
then what does that mean that means that
you could apply it to this graph and it
would distinguish between the cases of
diameter at least three in diameter two
and therefore it would tell you which of
these two cases you're in and tell you
whether or not there exists a pair of
disjoint sets thereby solving OV
okay are there any
um questions about this reduction I'm
happy to answer anything I lost about
the uh the role of the sparsity here it
should be seen because the graph is
being dense but it's I think I lost
track of that yeah so this is for the
sparse case so we it's important that we
construct these graphs so that they are
sparse in particular these graphs are
sparse and we're allowing log factors so
these graphs are sparse because the size
of this is only going to be log n
and so the number of Ed like every
vertex here only has degree at most log
n so the total number of edges is
you know end times login or so
I see I think the the point that was
missing is that if the graph is dense
then you're you're allowing yourself a
higher complexity to solve the
environment that's
yes if the graph is dense
um what changes with this reduction if
the garage is dead what changes okay
yeah so this shouldn't say anything
about dense graphs like this tells you
that this tells you that like you can't
solve diameter any faster than
um
N squared sorry you can't get an
approximation better any better than N
squared we already
um okay
they're allows aircraft to be dead then
you're saying well I can run on time and
queue and then this reduction is doesn't
say anything interesting just creating a
graph will take you quicker at a time
it's not going to give you anything
better than quadratic I mean the
statement is kind of backwards for damn
scrubs exactly yeah
no the graph is the same but anyways
the reduction or taken Square time if
it's dense so then you don't get
anything
why is that because
if you if you make it this the running
time will be in terms is the number of
edges If it creates you know dense means
and squares
it's important there's a reduction from
the low Dimension OV
right you mean you can think of other
dimensions but but that's what governs
the size of The Clique on the right hand
side is the dimensionality
yeah you can have a larger Dimension and
you get another problem yeah so I think
the
confusion's head uh is uh keep us in
dimensionality but to replace a sponge
crops with the statement about
spacecraft statements about dense graphs
so what changes into on this slide um
what's the strange the theorem is
trivially like false implies false
yeah so then you get um so it's still
true but like who cares yeah it's
packages
you can't get less than squared
let's be good thank you okay
okay
anything else
you can also think of it as if the
number if you're the size of the graph
is M the number of edges then it will be
about being m to the two minus Epsilon
instead of n right
I can't think of what that would
be dense
a little bit in terms of the numbers
okay so now I want to just tell you
without proving anything some of the
newer developments uh about the diameter
problem
and these are things that have happened
just within the last couple of years and
are still actively happening and so what
it turns out that we can do
is get a Time versus accuracy trade-off
just by assuming the OV hypothesis
um so my goal is not for you to
understand this whole picture but I just
want to point out some important things
in it so on the x-axis there's the
approximation Factor
on the y-axis there's the running time
exponent so for example and in all of
these points here are known algorithms
and all of these boxes here are known
conditional lower bounds that is to say
if you have one of these boxes what that
means is that conditionally you cannot
get an algorithm that's going to fall
into one of these boxes
okay so what this is saying is like you
know if your approximation factor is one
that's just for exact algorithms this is
just the trivial alt rental pair of
shortest paths and squared time
algorithm and it turns out that you can
get some sub quadratic time algorithms
which are these ones
and then as you go down the
approximation factors get worse and
worse
and this work has been able to
um get some it's not completely tight
but some of these points are tight and
um we've shown that there's like an if
you believe Seth then there's an
inherent time versus accuracy trade-off
uh some of these trade-off uh things are
only for undirected graphs and just in
very recent work like a couple months
ago by Virginia and others um they
showed that for directed graphs you can
also get some trade-off
this algorithm
specifically assumes possible or does it
like happen to running and for running
time yeah good question so the question
is about
how they out
for example this algorithm runs in time
M times square root of n where n is the
number of edges so it if you have a
denser graph then you do get you do get
that M times square root of that
um is it easy to see why the what you
showed on the previous slide implies
something for a truly multiplicative
bound like if I allowed a plus one why
doesn't the construction collapse okay
so you're asking about out like um you
want to have a reduction that gives uh
separation instead of between two and
three between like two L and 3L for any
value of L for example
um it turns out that you can do that but
uh you need like you can add a couple of
extra gadgets to the graph and you can
get that
good question
rights review
yeah so what you do is you pick an
arbitrary vertex run dijkstra's
algorithm from it and just take the
biggest distance and then you can show
that
in like one step of approved by the
triangle inequality this is at least
half of half a diameter which gives you
a two approximation and one of the kind
of cool things about this recent work is
that it actually showed that if you
restrict yourself to linear time
algorithms or near linear time
algorithms the best you can hope for is
just that say that trivial algorithm
okay so now um if there are more
questions I'm going to move on to the
second part of the talk which is
disjoint from the first it is about the
dense graph regime when the number of
edges in the graph
N squared and we're trying to beat cubic
time
okay
so now the question that we're asking is
can you solve these problems
eccentricities diameter radius Etc
um in subcubic time
and the answer here turns out to be kind
of interesting it turns out to be no you
can't do it under the all pair shortest
path hypothesis that Virginia mentioned
earlier however it's actually not known
for diameter so for all of these other
ones radius eccentricities
Etc
you can show that they are actually sub
cubically equivalent to the all pair
shortest paths problem but we don't know
for diameter and this is one of the big
open questions in the area for all we
know diameter on dense graphs could be
in N squared time
okay
so here's the theorem all pair shortest
path is equivalent to radius median and
other problems under these sub-cubic
fine-grained reductions and you'll
notice that this is actually different
from the sparse case in the sense that
in the dense case we're actually showing
equivalence we're showing it in both
directions in the sparse case we were
only showing it in one direction from OV
to diameter and so in the dense case we
actually have this kind of whole web of
equivalences between a bunch of
different problems and let me just
clarify what the definition of
equivalence means and said if you have a
truly subquadratic time algorithm for
problem B it can be converted into a
truly sub-quadratic time algorithm for
problem a perhaps with these Epsilon and
Delta being different values
okay so now let me show you
um before I show you what the world
looks like in terms of the web of
reductions let me say a little bit more
about this all pair shortest path
hypothesis which is that you can't do
anything better than you can't do it in
truly sub cubic time for weighted graphs
like Virginia said
and this is kind of some
evidence that it might be a hard problem
there is just a very long line of work
that was shaving logs and shaving more
logs until Ryan told everyone okay you
can stop shaving logs now
okay so this is a big open problem is
all pairs shortest fast and truly sub
cubic time and this is what we use as
our hypothesis that it's not
that's the apsp hypothesis
okay so now here's the web of reductions
for dense graphs
and you'll notice that this is a
strongly connected graph and so what
that means is that everybody on the
screen is actually sub cubically
equivalent to everybody else
and there's a bunch of different
problems and I won't uh Define them all
so
you start with the apsp hypothesis
and then what we're going to see today
is this part of the
picture we may not get all the way to
this one but what I really want to
communicate to you is how to get from
apsp to negative triangle because that
was as you can see from this picture a
very influential result by uh Virginia
and Ryan from 2010
and you can see that once we had the
reduction to negative triangle you can
go from here to everybody else
and this is like a significant step
because for apsp you'll notice that the
output is of size N squared and suddenly
for negative triangle all you're trying
to do is is return like one bit is there
a negative triangle in the graph
okay so my my main goal for this second
part is to show you some ideas for how
to go from apsp to negative triangle
okay so the first step is to go from
apsp to this distance product that was
mentioned earlier so that's this Arrow
this is kind of the I guess
more definitional less interesting part
of the reduction it has been known since
1971 it's basically saying that there is
a distance product that can exactly
capture apsp and in particular that
product is defined as follows so like in
regular matrix multiplication you're
doing multiplying and adding whereas
here we're doing
adding and taking the minimum so this is
a like a product that you can take over
to matrices and the statement here is
that
these two like apsp in this distant
projects are actually equivalent and for
what we're going to do today is to
reduce from distance product to apsp
okay so what you do here is you take
your instance of distance product you're
given these
uh two matrices A and B that you want to
take the distance product of
um you take the and then you consider
that as the weighted adjacency Matrix of
the graph
so
um you you say that the number in the
like UV position of the Matrix is going
to be considered the weight of the Edge
from U to V
I think you're going from apsp to
distance yes that's what I realized just
now as well thank you
um
okay so this is like the wrong
this thing is the proof for the arrow in
the other direction
I'm just saying the words wrong thank
you okay
okay so we're given and we're given an
arbitrary instance of the distance
product problem and we want to
oh no it's from graphs
if you can solve business for you can
solve service pass so you take shortest
pass oh this arrow is not like it's the
opposite direction of the previous slide
okay thank you good so we're given an
arbitrary instance of all pair shortest
paths we would like to convert it into a
um an instance of the distance product
so what we're going to do is we have our
graph we have all the weights on our
graph now we're going to construct a
matrix this Matrix in the UV entry is
going to have
um an entry that has weight UV the
weight of the edge UV it's going to have
Infinity for the non-edges and it's
going to have 0 for U equals to V
and what you'll notice if you stare at
this for a little bit is that if you
take the kth power of the Matrix then
what you're going to get is the weight
of the shortest path on at most K edges
in the graph
because if you think about what a
shortest path is in a graph it's like
I can go from
a Vertex to another vertex through an
intermediate vertex and I'm going to
take the sum over the two edges and I
want to take the minimum intermediate
vertex that gives me the shortest path
okay so how you can get this is by doing
successive squaring
of this Matrix to get all the way up to
a to the N which would give you the
weight of the shortest path on any
number of edges in the graph and this
successive squaring is just going to add
a log factor to
the
the running time
sorry so by squaring you mean use the
distance product or equal to square it
yes
okay thank you for the correction I hope
uh if I confused you which is totally
valid we can
I can go through to get offline
okay
so it means that if I can solve the
distance product in quadratic time or
better than quadratic time cubic
distance
I can solve espos and Better Than People
yes okay thank you okay and this is
maintenance multiplication on the
tropical semi yes
yes
but for Keon is asking we can think
about the so the distance products of
the tropical Cemetery
also I think we're using a switch to
another symboli perhaps it says
something about the complex problems
there's a faker I think maybe it's
Fisher in my way so this shortest pass
is the transitive closure under the semi
right and so if you take a different
simmering a similar sort of reduction
would work under some conditions oh
that's a meaning
so for a class of symmetics this problem
is equivalent yes
and in fact Fisher and I got rid of the
log yeah he's a big Oak Tina
oh okay good so now comes um really the
part that I want to emphasize here which
is how do you go from this distance
product down to this negative triangle
problem
and you can do it uh and so just to
define the negative triangle problem
we're just asking given a graph it has
weights some of the weights can be
negative and
uh we're asking
is there a negative a negative weight
triangle in the graph so you add up all
the edges in the triangle is it negative
you can do a cubic time algorithm by
trying all triples and what we're
showing here is that you can't do
significantly better than this trivial
algorithm
if you assume the aps APS
okay so there are two steps to this
reduction and there's an intermediate
problem and the intermediate problem is
perhaps what you would expect the
intermediate problem to be maybe which
is that you can go from distance product
to all pairs negative triangles that is
to say for every pair of vertices in the
graph we want to Output is this pair in
a negative triangle
and then the second step is the step
where you're going from the output size
being N squared to the output size being
just one single number you're going from
all pairs of negative triangles to just
asking is there a negative triangle
so first let's look at the first one so
our goal here is to go from distance
product to all pairs negative triangles
and the reduction is the following
okay so what we would like to do is
we're now given an arbitrary instance of
distance product we would like to create
a graph out of it such that if you can
solve all pairs negative triangles on
this graph then you've solved to
distance product okay so let's look at
this example these A and B these are the
two matrices that we would like to take
the distance product of and what we're
going to do
is just make a graph that has three
pieces and we're going to add edges from
let's say from like I to K that have uh
so I'm going to add an edge from this
first vertex to this first vertex with
weight one because there's a one in the
position one one there's a five in the
position two one and so I'm going to go
from the second vertex to the first
vertex with weight five
but okay so then on the other side I'm
going to be doing exactly the same thing
but now I'm going to be considering the
weights three two and two inside of this
Matrix
okay so now what we would like to show
is that if you can solve all pairs
negative triangle then you can solve
distance product and to do that we need
to add some more edges to the graph in
particular we need to add some edges of
negative weight
so what we're going to do is add some
edges in this direction to form some
triangles here and these edges are going
to have some carefully chosen weights
so in particular you'll notice that
I'm adding an edge in this direction it
has weight negative eight and you can
see that there's a path of two and two
so this is a negative triangle
and if I were to change this weight to
like negative
you know negative four then this would
give me a triangle of exactly zero but
if it was negative five it would give me
yes there's a negative triangle so that
is to say if you set this to negative
five you get the answer yes if you set
it to negative four you get the answer
no and so our goal is to find the
threshold of uh when the negative
triangle when there is a negative
triangle and when there's not a negative
triangle and that tells us what is the
distance between these two vertices
which is what we want to compute
okay so the way that we're going to do
that is we would like to find like the
special Edge weight for each one of
these edges going in the backwards
Direction
and what we're going to do is a
simultaneous binary search
that is to say we're simultaneously
doing a binary search over all possible
edges in this direction and we only need
to repeat this log n times because each
the binary search is only going to take
uh login calls to negative triangle
and then in the end you get that if the
weights are at most polynomial then only
login calls to negative triangle to
sorry to all pairs negative triangles
suffice so every time you call all pairs
negative triangle you get an output of
an N by n Matrix which tells you for
each of these pairs is there a negative
triangle and then you adjust the weights
accordingly
is that okay yes
so you're adding red edges for good
questions because there's only two in
this picture so you're adding red edges
for all of the different pairs so I'm
adding like the size of J times the size
of I for for every possible one of these
pairs I'm adding a red Edge and I'm
doing simultaneous binary search over
all of them
sorry so in the distance product the
instance uh you're using numbers one
integers one two in and infinity
those are the like what's the range of
entries that you're using yes
yes that's what I'm using
the range is polynomials here over there
it says enter the C okay
I I think I'm lost with a simultaneously
um find the research can you can you
please setting this again yes so
so let's just look at this one
this one can do binary search by doing
uh login calls to all pairs negative
triangle every time we get the output of
all pairs negative triangle we look at
the IJ entry and we say did this tell me
yes or no and then I adjust this weight
accordingly until I find the correct
threshold between yes or no so now I'm
going to do that simultaneously for all
of these so I pick a weight for all of
these edges then I get my output for
um all pairs of negative triangle
in my output is in size N squared so it
tells me whether or not there's a
negative triangle for all of these
different pairs
and then I look at what's I look at that
Matrix I say I look at which ones where
and which ones weren't negative
triangles and then I simultaneously
update all N squared of these edges so I
think the important bit here is that you
don't get a yes or no answer they don't
get the binary answer but you really get
a report of all the negative times
right here then you know which which way
you want to adjust up or down two points
exactly so importantly you noted that
um this reduction here is to all pairs
negative triangles so we're really using
the fact that the output is all of the
pairs negative triangle and next what
we're going to do is reduce from all
pairs negative triangle down to just the
binary answer of is there a negative
triangle we haven't done that one yet
but is it one call or several calls in
the way you had set up
right now sort of login
s so you have a waste yeah
so now we're moving on to the second
part where we're trying to reduce all
pairs negative triangle down to negative
triangle this is the part where the
output goes from size N squared to just
one bit
okay
so this is just what we showed for in
the first reduction
okay so now our goal is the following
all pairs negative triangle to negative
triangle and we so we would like to take
an instance of all pairs negative
triangle and solve it using an algorithm
for just negative triangle
and the way that this works is the
following so we're gonna have to make
like a bunch of instances of negative
triangle because each of them is only
going to give us one bit and in the end
we need N squared bits
okay so what we're going to do is we're
given an instance of all pairs negative
triangle we take this graph and just
imagine that we copy the graph three
times
and I'm going to just put an edge
between like this vertex A1 to A2 if
there was an edge between from A1 to A2
in the original graph so so far I'm just
doing kind of a a trivial transformation
to take this graph and make it into a
tripartite graph so that all of the
triangles are going to go between these
two so
now this this graph actually has more
triangles than the original graph
because I'm like copying each one but
that's fine all we need to find is
um for each pair does it have a negative
triangle
okay so what are we going to do we're
going to take each of these copies
and we're going to split it into
different pieces and each of these
pieces are going to be of size s so this
one is of size S size S size s we do the
same thing with all of these and then
what we're going to do is to consider
all n over s cubed triples of pieces
so I could take this piece with this
piece with this piece
and that's going to be one instance of
uh or maybe we're going to then find the
negative triangles within each triple
separately
okay so we have created multiple
instances now we've divided into pieces
and we're going to consider each triple
uh separately and do a separate
algorithm for each one which is going to
involve some calls to negative triangle
so this is kind of the high level idea
and now let me say a couple more details
about how you actually implement this
so what we do is remember again we're
trying to solve all pairs of negative
triangles so our output is going to be
an N by n Matrix where every entry of
the Matrix is going to correspond to is
there a negative triangle with this that
contain this particular pair of vertices
so we're just going to initialize our
Matrix to be all zeros and then we're
going to gradually fill it in
so we're going to do for every triple
for every one of these triples of pieces
we're going to say
run negative triangle on it it might
return yes and it might return no
if it returns if it returns no then we
know that there's no negative triangle
in these particular pieces and we can
just zero out that section of The Matrix
on the other hand if it returns yes then
we know we have found a negative
triangle but it might not be the only
negative triangle that's in these
particular pairs so what we're going to
do is we find a negative triangle here
and then we're going to set that entry
of the Matrix to 1 because we
successfully found a negative triangle
and then
we're going to set the weight of this
Edge now to Infinity
and when it's set to Infinity that means
that it's no longer going to belong to
any more negative triangles
that is if we again
or of individual nodes
good so uh their individual nodes so I
ran a negative triangle on groups and I
found a specific negative triangle on
these three specific notes no no the XYZ
are over the groups the a x a y a z are
the notes yes in this slide yes
so I so ax a y a z each of these is a
vertex
yeah so there's three groups on each of
them so I X ranges from one to three y
one to three Z one two three
um did did that answer your question
okay good so let's scoot let's go again
indices of groups the indices of groups
and a little overload in notation that
ax is the node that you found in IX
you can say it right he says
you cannot if you can detect you can
find so we haven't said that
yeah see this this thing as soon as you
can find but there's another exercise
for The Listener to there's an exercise
to The Listener that if if there's an
algorithm that can detect a negative
triangle then you can also find one in
the same time
roughly
it's like this afternoon
help me here
okay I'm not sure if let me just do a
little summary of that for everybody so
um
the last thing that was said was um when
we run negative triangle we've just
assumed that we actually got a negative
triangle back but the definition of the
problem is just telling us does there
exist a negative triangle or does there
not so really what we're getting is just
does there exist one in these three
squares and and does they're not but um
as Ryan mentioned it's an exercise for
the The Listener to to to also go to the
search problem so the claim is that if
you can actually detect whether or not
there is one then you can actually find
it
as well and I won't say how to do that
but for this reduction we are assuming
that we're actually given the real
triangle
okay so what have we done so far
we took each one of these triples
and we asked does it have a negative
triangle
and it returned a negative triangle if
the answer was yes and the negative
triangle could for example have been A3
A4 A5
then what we're going to do is set the
weight of A3 A5 in in this graph we're
going to update the weight to be
Infinity
the reason we're going to do that is so
that if we again call negative triangle
on this same three pieces we're not just
going to find the same negative triangle
over and over again so we need to set
the weight to Infinity so that it's
going to return a different negative
triangle until we found all of the
negative triangles
okay so just as a
just to clarify here
you might
so we only need to find the negative
triangles that that involve pairs so to
solve the all pairs negative triangle
problem we only need to find the
negative triangles that involve one
vertex in I and one in J we don't need
to worry about the ones that are like in
these different pairs and the reason for
that is because I just made a copy of
the whole graph so we're we're only
caring about the the
um the pair is where one is in here and
one is in here
and
for that reason we're allowed to just
set the weight of a to of this Edge to
uh to Infinity when we found a negative
triangle
because this this Edge does not
participate in any of the other negative
triangles that we're trying to find
between I and J
okay so so this is the algorithm and
then at the end we return this Matrix C
and again the reason that we're setting
it to Infinity is so that we can we can
we just keep on running all we just keep
on running the negative triangle
algorithm until it returns no in which
case we can stop and we do that
separately for each one of these triples
okay so now you can like do the running
time analysis here and you can say okay
what is the running time well it's the
number of triples
because we for each of the triples we
ran a negative triangle algorithm but
then additionally every time we found a
try a negative triangle
we ran it again on that same triple
until we didn't find any more
and so the running time is going to be
the time for a negative triangle times
the number of triples plus the number of
triangles that we found
okay so now we can kind of do some
parameter balancing and the number of
triples is n over s cubed the number of
triangles is at most N squared because
it's all pairs negative triangle which
then there's the most N squared pairs
so let's suppose negative triangles in
time capital N to the D where n is the
number of vertices in the graph
then this becomes
um this becomes the following running
time if we set s to be n to the one
third and we did that to balance the
parameters
and what this means is that this running
time is sub cubic if D is less than
three that is to say if you have a sub
cubic time algorithm for negative
triangle then this whole entire
procedure runs also in sub cubic time
okay are there any questions about this
if you know that there is one you can
find one is it because you took small
groups I mean does it does it appear in
the
algorithm yes yeah there's a reduction
that also partitions into groups so you
call the detection on the middle of uh
parameterizing the S this is where it uh
where it's it where it's laser roll and
that's a separate Productions the
this is so productive
production then you've kind of grown a
recursion one the one that says that it
contains one
I think your question was can you do the
search to detection reduction even if
your graph is not these small groups if
it's the whole graph and the answer is
yes you can still do it for sure
what is this picture okay so
um in this picture we're making so
s is going to be this the size of each
group so splitting we're splitting these
into pieces of size s
this is us and then at the end s is
going to be set so s is 2 here but it's
going to be set to n to the 1 3 in
general
nothing else
yes
like even for the distant product yes
yes uh question was does it also work
for undirected graphs and the answer is
yes
okay so now um in the interest of time
let me say something a bit more high
level so I'm not going to go through the
reduction from negative triangle to
radius
um if you're curious you can come talk
to me or Virginia or Ryan
so there's going to be like a pretty
complicated picture coming up which you
can ignore
and now let's talk about something a
little bit more high level
so just in general we talked about these
two problems of radius and diameter
and it turned out it turns out that in
the literature any time we can find an
algorithm for diameter
it turns out that it has carried over to
radius and vice versa but the same is
not true for these conditional lower
bounds
and in particular
these two problems differ in like the
quantifiers like min max max versus min
max and this seems to kind of create
some issues for making these lower
bounds
and in particular you'll recall that in
dense graphs we have a reduction from
apsp to radius but we don't know how to
make it go through to diameter so that
was the part the the part where you go
to radius that was the part that I
didn't show you so if you want to get a
sense for why it might not work for
diameter then uh we'll be happy to talk
it talk about it offline
and then it also turns out that we know
some problems that are equivalent to
diameter in in dense graphs
um so we know something but we just
don't know whether you can reduce from
apsp to diameter in dense graphs and
then on the other side of the spectrum
it turns out that
these in sparse graphs we have like this
whole time versus accuracy trade-off
there was that picture we have that only
for diameter and we don't have it for
radius and so it's kind of interesting
that like in dense graphs versus in
sparse graphs radius and diameter seem
uh like diameters diameter is harder
than radius or so it seems in one regime
and the opposite is true in the other
regime
so these these pose some interesting
open problems that I'll put here so
these these two first open problems are
trying to get radius and diameter to
match up with each other so can we get
hardness for diameter and dense graphs
and can we get approximate more
approximation trade-off hardness for
radius in sparse graphs
let me mention also a couple more open
problems so this is the pro the thing
that was brought up earlier but about
like sparse versus dents and so far
we're kind of have these reductions that
work in either case and maybe there's
some way to unify it a bit better
um and then there's also this question
of approximation in dense graphs we only
talked about approximation in sparse
graphs and there and these dense graph
reductions don't Preserve
approximability
and then you can also if you're
particularly interested in diameter and
there's a whole bunch of different
variants of diameter Etc that Yin Jin
has worked on as well
um you can look at my PhD thesis and
there's an open problem section or I can
send it to you
okay uh thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
let me put up these takeaways question
are there interesting separations
between Direct
ORS there actually are so to give you
one particular example
it turns out that if you consider radius
in the sparse case for directed graphs
um and versus radius in the sparse case
for undirected graphs it turns out that
for directed graphs you can get a very
strong lower bound which says that
basically there's this like linear time
algorithm that we know and if you want
to get anything better than than the
approximation factor for this linear
time algorithm that immediately jumps up
to N squared that is to say in the
picture for diameter before it was like
this whole staircase thing but for
directed radius it's literally just
like that
um and the same we don't and for
undirected radius this is an open
problem
so we I guess kind of suspect that it
should be similar to undirected diameter
where you get the whole trade-off
all right are there any fine-grained
complexity results for three weeks okay
when you fix the three weeks you don't
seem to know better yeah good question
so the question was about tree with so
parametrizing by the the graph parameter
tree width and whether there's fine
grain reductions known for this so there
was actually a paper from 2016 with
Virginia and
um uh two others who where they studied
in particular diameter for bounded tree
with graphs and they showed that you can
get some uh sub quadratic time
algorithms for exact diameter if you
parameterize actually my question was
the other detecting three weeks
yes
for the exact case here
for approximations you can get C to the
K foreign
[Music]
um so you're asking about Computing a
cubic feet
for dense graphs if you would see them a
particular like some structure of the
graph
well for example there's these results
where you uh on average you can solve it
in N squared time for example like if
you sample the weights from uniformly
from a range from zero to one then you
can do basically quadratic
and there's other results too
there are also if you assume something
geometric about the graph then you can
also get some
um speed UPS
oh yes
thank you for sticking around
[Applause]